[Music]
no stable tool in a human arsenal
explains our existence more than fire
one of the things we talk about in the
show is that on the one hand fire is one
of the most destructive forces right
like you can cook your food on the one
hand but you can also like burn your
village early humans quickly discovered
that fire was a very destructive force
at the same time however when
domesticated when harnessed it
eventually would lead us to power our
jet engine you know controlled
explosions even in a car is what makes
engines work and so it's this capacity
that human beings have to harness to
creatively harness potentially
destructive forces and use them towards
creative ends that I think is amazing
we are a fire species these are the
stories that have made us human this is
our evolution the neverending journey we
have only our past to help us navigate
and face our future
[Music]